Mountains snow and freezing wind
the road to oatlu has little Comfort to
offer
it's long winding and climbs tiringly
I'm not sure what a road to total
devastation should look like but the
scenes along the way give plenty of
ideas
the villagers nestled on a mountain peak
in Southeastern turkia
it's a hard place to reach by Road a few
days ago we briefly visited the village
on board a military helicopter sent to
deliver Aid the military are taking the
boxes and we're looking for the people
where what happened to The Villages
but we were asked to stay on the
helicopter and not delay the mission we
left with many unanswered questions it's
really an emotionally hard moment
because I want to get out and talk to
those people
so we've now come back to the Village by
road to find those answers as soon as we
arrive we find old clue in mourning
nazifer gunar is receiving condolences
after losing her daughter and three
grandchildren
we were terrified we couldn't escape I
fell down the stairs it was shaking so
badly wherever you look the earthquake
has left its mark on the landscape on
houses and of course on people's minds
authorities say they're going to start
reconstruction efforts in a matter of
weeks but clearly it's going to be a
long process
same for elephant batala cash time is in
short supply
we caught a glimpse of batal the day we
flew in on a helicopter we tracked him
down to hear his story
what do I do where shall I go
my blood pressure is rising I am ill
distractor was my right hand it's gone
I built this house I invested in this
house it's all gone
I'm 80 years old
the elderly couple live alone in a tent
supplied by the authorities
her home and her sense of security lie
crushed outside it's difficult to
imagine the terror people felt as their
homes Came Crashing Down unless your
Muhammad Shaheen the 16 year old
miraculously survived not only the
earthquake but two days trapped in the
rubble of his own home
I heard a terrible sounds like an
explosion I fell off my bed and it went
dark there was a lot of dust and there
was a concrete block on me I could not
feel my feet from the cold I thought I
was going to die
memories like that are hard to erase
from your mind
this is a teenager who dreams of a
little peace of mind and a little more
food in his tent it's just so they just
we just need a little more grains and
water
authorities are delivering food tents
and on this day firewood too
a moment of relief for fun for the kids
much harder to deliver on the back of a
truck though the blades of our
helicopter did the trick a few days
earlier it's heartbreaking to look down
and see these kids as we
away from the window
but today we exchange hugs on the same
spot
smile a laugh and a little light
brightens up the horizon
Sami zaydan Al Jazeera old turkia